Me fizeram a seguinte pergunta:
suplementar vitaminas do complexo B, B6,
B9, B12 para reduzirína pode atrasar o
decl cognitivo? E a minha intenção aqui
hoje vai ser responder essa pergunta de
uma maneira que seja o mais aproveitável
possível pro maior número possível de
pessoas. Então eu vou aqui ser o mais
didático e responder de uma maneira que
agrade,
um erro fatal que milhões de pessoas bem
intencionadas cometem todos os dias ao
tomar vitamina B12 e que esse erro, em
vez de proteger o cérebro, pode estar,
na verdade, acelerando o caminho para os
Heimer.
Pois é, a verdade que muitas vezes não
te contam na consulta de 15 minutos é
que não basta tomar B12, você precisa da
forma certa para realmente blindar a sua
mente. O que eu vou te revelar aqui hoje
é a diferença entre jogar dinheiro fora
e investir na sua lucidez para o futuro.
Fica comigo. Pra gente entender esse
rolo todo, eu preciso te apresentar um
personagem que talvez o seu médico nunca
tenha mencionado uma consulta. O nome
dele é homocisteína.
Pense no homocisteína como se fosse o
colesterol do cérebro. Quando ela está
alta no seu sangue, ela age como uma
lixa, irritando infamando as paredes dos
seus vasos sanguíneos, inclusive os
pequeninos vasos que irrigam o seu
cérebro. Ela vai danificando a fiação
dos seus neurônios, enferrujando o
sistema e abrindo as portas para o
nevoeiro mental e no longo prazo para o
declínio cognitivo. E o mais louco é que
medir a unciteína é simples, um exame de
sangue que custa uma merreca, mas é um
dos marcadores mais ignorados na prática
médica convencional.
Eles esperam a casa pegar fogo para
depois tentar apagar o incêndio. Uma
abordagem funcional busca os sinais de
fumaça. E a um sistema na alta é um
baita sinal de fumaça. Agora vamos ao
ponto principal, onde a porca torce o
rabo. Você percebe que precisa de B12,
vai na farmácia e compra a mais comum, a
mais barata. E o nome no rótulo ciano
cobalamina. Presta atenção nesse nome,
cianocobalamina.
Esse ciano vem de cianeto. Sim, aquele
cianeto é uma molécula minúscula e
segura em dose de suplemento, mas seu
corpo precisa primeiro se livrar desse
caneto e depois gastar uma energia
danada para tentar converter a
cobalamina em uma forma que ele consiga
usar.
E o pior, uma galera, mas uma galera
mesmo, tem uma variação genética, famosa
MTHFR,
que dificulta essa conversão. É como dar
um bloco de metal para uma pessoa e
pedir para ela fazer uma chave, só que a
máquina dela para cortar a chave está
meio quebrada, não vai funcionar
direito. Você toma, mas não absorve.
Aína continua alta e o seu cérebro
desprotegido.
Esse é o erro fatal. Então, qual é o
segredo? Qual é a forma certa? O nome
que você precisa procurar é
metilcobalamina B12 metilada. Pensa nela
com a chave que já vem prontinha,
cortada, pronta para entrar na fechadura
e fazer o trabalho. Então, ela não
precisa de conversão. O corpo a
reconhece e usa imediatamente ela já vem
ativada. Mas não adianta só trocar a
B12, achar que resolveu e sair cantando
pneu. A B12 é a estrela do time, a
atacante, mas ela não ganha o jogo
sozinha. Ela precisa de uma parceria
forte no meio de campo e na zaga. O
parceiro número um dela é a vitamina B9,
mas de novo, não é qualquer uma. Esquece
o ácido fólico, a forma sintética que
está em todo lugar. E para quem tem
aquela mesma questão genética, pode até
mais atrapalhar do que ajudar. O nome do
craque aqui é metilfolato.
É a B9 já na sua forma ativa prontinha
para o jogo. E para fechar a tríade da
salvação do seu cérebro, a gente precisa
da vitamina B6 também na sua forma
ativa, que se chama piridoxal 5 fosfato
ou P5P para facilitar. Então, esse trio
metobalamina, metofolato e P5P trabalha
em uma sintonia perfeita. Eles pegam
aquela homocisteína que estava alta,
circulando, inflamando, e a reciclam,
transformando-a em substâncias úteis pro
corpo, como a gluta o nosso mestre
antioxidante. Eles limpam o terreno e
protegem os seus neurônios. Agora eu te
pergunto, olhando no fundo dos seus
olhos, você já mediu a sua mociteína?
Você já parou para ler o rótulo da sua
vitamina B12 e vê se está tomando
acianocobalamina ou a metilcobalamina?
Às vezes as decisões mais importantes
pra nossa saúde no futuro estão nesses
pequenos detalhes que a maioria das
pessoas ignora. O que eu te passei aqui
hoje é muito mais do que uma dica, é uma
estratégia de longevidade cerebral.
Saia do vídeo agora se você gosta de
ficar no superficial. Eu vou te contar
uma verdade inconveniente. O YouTube e o
conselho de medicina me limitam. Aqui eu
preciso simplificar, censurar dosagens,
omitir protocolos controversos. Na
comunidade fechada não tem esse filtro.
Eu compartilho os exatos protocolos que
eu uso na minha clínica. Casos de
reversão que parecem possíveis,
combinações of label que funcionam,
fornecedores confiáveis, interpretação
avançada de exames. É basicamente ter
acesso ao meu cérebro médico sem
intermediários. Live semanais
respondendo perguntas, PDF com 47
protocolos exclusivos, grupo no
WhatsApp. Se você quer a visão funcional
real, sem simplificação para as massas,
clique em seja membro. E não é para
curiosos, é para quem quer resultados.